- [Judge] Then let us begin with
your opening statement Mr. Payne.
- Whoa, opening statement?
So how can you give an opening statement
and summarize your case
if you have no idea
what your case is or
what the case is about?
That's, that's bad news
for Phoenix Wright.
(upbeat music)
Hey legal eagles D. James
Stone here teaching you
how to think like a lawyer.
Today we're covering Phoenix
Wright, Ace Attorney,
a anime manga based on a video game
that was written in Japanese
and translated into english
so who knows what we're
gonna to get into today.
My understanding based on your comments
is that this isn't based on
any particular legal system
but it's a combination of the
Japanese and American system.
I am not an expert in
the Japanese legal system
so I will be looking at
this through the lens
of an American attorney because
that's what I know best.
If I get something wrong
please leave me a comment
in the form of an objection.
As the judge and jury in this
case I will either sustain
or over rule your objection
based on it's legal merit.
And as always stick around
until the end of the video
where I give Phoenix Wright Ace Attorney
a grade for legal realism.
So without further ado let's dig right in
to Phoenix Wright, Ace Attorney.
Defense lawyer Phoenix Wright, okay.
- [Phoenix] I just earned
my badge a few months.
- Hey I think I recognize that area.
So that looks like the Naka
Meguro area of Tokyo along
the Meguro river where they
have all the cherry blossoms.
Really pretty area of Tokyo.
- [Phoenix] So I'm still a rookie.
- Did he say he got a badge?
In the US at least, you don't get a badge.
Police officers get badges.
You take the state bar exam
and you become admitted to the bar
and you don't wear any
sort of lapel pin except
for maybe an American flag lapel pin so...
don't know what jurisdiction
actually issues a badge,
potentially a gun, to
their defense attorneys.
(upbeat music)
- [Phoenix] In fact
I'm beginning arguments
in my first real trial today.
- So he is on his first day as an attorney
and he's giving an argument in a trial
that's, that's pretty crazy.
Trials take months,
sometimes years to litigate
and you would never start on day one
giving an argument as a new attorney.
That's not something
that should ever happen,
if it does something went
terribly, terribly wrong.
- Always so ambitious.
This is a homicide case,
not many people would take
one on for their first trial.
- Yeah also most defendants
in a homicide case
would not ever use an attorney
who had never done any sort
of trial work before and
it was their first day,
that's definitely not what you
want in a defense attorney.
- I know what I'm
getting myself into boss.
- Do you?
- But I had to take it
because I owe it to him.
- Oh what's the significance
of the key chain?
- The defendant?
- Yes.
Actually I've known the
guy ever since we were
in grade school, he's part of the reason
I wanted to be a defense
lawyer in the first place.
- [Boss] Let's hope
you can clear his name.
- Ah okay so Phoenix Wright
apparently knows the defendant.
That can be very problematic
because you don't want your
emotions to get in the way
of your defense, you have
certain ethical obligations
to your client and if your
emotions get in the way of that
and also if you're a
witness who might testify
to the character of that defendant
then you would mainly be conflicted out
of representing them so
there's a lot of issues here
representing someone who
is a childhood friend,
I would never recommend for
someone to represent someone
that they know so well,
that's, that's not a good idea.
- There's no way he's guilty
but how will I convince the judge?
- Do you not have any
evidence at this point?
Have you not spoken to your client?
Okay and they're separating people.
So this is a very ornate court room
that would be more suited
to an appeals court,
not a trial court at the criminal level.
Winston Payne, the prosecutor.
- [Phoenix] That's my
client, good old Larry Butz.
- Okay that's an interesting name.
- [Phoenix] He and I go
way back, to say the least.
And you've been dreaming of.
- And he's apparently
wearing the same thing
that he was wearing on
the day of the murder.
You wanna put your client
in the best light forward
so that's why defense
attorneys, if they have to,
will provide a suit and
tie to their clients
in order to make them look a little better
than if they'd just
walked in off the street.
You would never want
to wear just a t-shirt
with some crazy hair
and a goatee to court,
you'd want to dress them up a little bit
so they don't look like a hooligan
like this guy kinda looks
like a frat guy or something.
- Don't forget, to argue a solid defense
you have to believe in
him, and his innocence.
- Right.
- Not necessarily.
All clients are owed an advocate
and often you are conflicted
because you may see the evidence
and you may believe they are guilty
or libel of what they're accused of.
I have heard from my
public defender friends,
those people who provide
defenses to the indigent
that it can actually be harder
if you truly believe
that someone is innocent.
If you aren't sure and you're
just giving them a defense
you can go through the motions
and you can give them the
best defense possible.
But if you really believe
that they're innocent
of a particular crime then
it can actually be harder
because you are worried
that they may go to jail
or be convicted of something
that they didn't do
which can actually make it
harder for public defenders.
(dramatic music)
The judge.
- This court is here by in session.
- Okay.
- We have been gathered
today to hear the case
against Mr. Larry Butz.
- The prosecution is ready your honor.
- All right.
- The defense is ready your honor.
- Then let us begin with your
opening statement Mr. Payne.
- Whoa, opening statement?
So (laughs) the opening statement is
what you give at the beginning of a trial.
And it seems like there
has been very little time
that has passed between
the day of the murder
and this day in court.
Larry Butz is apparently
wearing the exact same thing
that he was wearing on
the day of the murder
and it doesn't seem like Phoenix Wright
has actually spoken to his client yet.
However, at the bare minimum you've gotta
talk to your client,
you've gotta talk to them,
you've gotta do some
investigation about the facts,
you've gotta conduct discovery.
The prosecution is obligated
to turn over the evidence
that they have to the defense
and you are obligated to
review that information
before the trial.
That he hasn't apparently
spoken to his client yet
and it's the day of trial
and he has to give an opening statement,
that's crazy how can you
give an opening statement
and summarize your case
if you have no idea
what your case is or
what the case is about?
That's, that's bad news
for Phoenix Wright.
- [Payne] We've identified
this statue out of
Rodin's the Thinker as the murder weapon.
- Alright.
- Which I would like to submit
to the court at this time.
- Generally exhibits would be determined
before the trial goes forward.
- [Judge] a modern representation.
- Didn't you just hear the lawyer guy?
It's Rodin, not Mo Dern,
and this was a gift I
made for my girlfriend.
- Do you mean you sculpted this.
- And why is he speaking?
This is opening statements,
the attorneys make an argument
or they say what the
evidence is going to show
for the rest of the trial,
this is not the time for
the criminal defendant
to say anything at all,
especially things that are inculpatory,
that's you need to get your client
to shut the hell up at this point.
- [Payne] Fingerprints
were indeed all over
the weapon your honor.
- Are you serious?
- Shut up, shut up.
- Your prints would be
all over it you idiot.
- In general, that's good advice
just tell you client to shut up.
- Let me state my case
man, I can't hang for this.
- The prosecution would
not like to call Mr. Butz
to the stand your honor.
- Is Phoenix Wright not get
to make an opening statement?
If trial has started then
prosecution will make
an opening statement and they will explain
what's going to happen during
the course of the trial,
it's generally not the time for argument.
Then there will be a recess
and the defense will be able to
make their opening statement.
So it is very problematic
that here the defense
is not allowed to make any
statement what so ever.
Now I don't know what opening
statement you could possibly
make when you have no
idea what the facts are,
you haven't spoken to you client
and you have no idea what
arguments are going to be made
and what's good for your
client and what's not
but still, he needs to be afforded
an opportunity to explain his case.
- [Payne] We also found a
photograph taken on this trip.
- [Larry] Huh?
That's the thinker.
- [Payne] Your honor I
would also like to submit
these items as evidence.
- [Judge] I'll accept them.
- Okay so the prosecutor
here has not laid any kind
of foundation to allow these
exhibits into evidence,
he's just simply said that
here's this photograph
and here's this passport,
he hasn't established that
those pieces of documentary
evidence are what they pro port to be
and he certainly hasn't
established through this witness
that the foundation has been laid.
You have to establish a foundation
before you're allowed
to bring evidence in.
But there's a more
fundamental problem here,
the first witness that
the prosecution has called
is the criminal defendant.
Now in the US at least criminal defendants
have a right against self incrimination
so they don't have to
testify if they don't want to
now if they do testify then the prosecutor
will get an opportunity to cross examine.
But it's crazy that the
first witness the prosecution
has called is the defendant
and the defense hasn't objected,
they have allowed this to go forward,
they are just asleep at
the wheel at this point
and this is really, really bad lawyering.
- Mr. Sahwit to the best
of your recollection
please tell the court what
you saw the day of the murder.
- Okay why is the judge
asking questions here?
Now sometimes a judge will
ask follow up questions,
they have a certain amount
of leeway in the court,
it's their court, they can
sort of do what they want.
But to start off the
examination it should be
the prosecutor, he should
be asking the questions,
laying the foundation
and establishing the
narrative of what happened,
it's improper for the judge
to be doing that kind
of in depth questioning.
- Why use a pay phone?
Was there not one closer to the scene?
- Yes but unfortunately due
to some utility repairs there
was a scheduled black out
in the area from one to six.
So he couldn't use it.
- The phone would be
completely inoperable.
- A black out?
- Alright again, the prosecutor
is not allowed to answer
questions in an examination
and the prosecutor can't
just magically pull out
some record and enter it into evidence,
especially in the middle of an examination
of a witness that has nothing
to do with that information.
This is very wacky.
- There you have it, the motive, weapon,
and a witness placing Butz at the scene.
(chuckles)
- Okay.
- Is something wrong?
- Is, is the prosecution resting here?
- Now Mr. Wright begin
your cross examination.
- Oh okay, so the defense finally gets to
cross examine a witness here.
Right now there's so many
constitutional violations
that this would be declared
a mistrial like immediately.
This would be over turned on appeal within
weeks of the verdict
coming down, this is crazy.
(dramatic music)
- You say you found the body at two p.m.,
are you absolutely certain of the time?
- [Sahwit] Yes without a doubt.
- But according to the
autopsy report the victim died
sometime after four p.m.,
it's right here in black and white,
- Okay now while this might
seem like a good argument,
you're contradicting the
witness with a coroners report.
You're really not allowed to
ask those kinds of questions
of this witness, this is a lay witness
who was there at the scene
but this witness is not
a coroner, not a doctor
and was not involved in
the autopsy of the victim
so he was no knowledge
about the autopsy report
and so whatever testimony he might have
is totally useless.
The only time that you
would want to bring up
the autopsy report is if
you called the coroner
up to the stand, which you
should in this particular case,
and what you would wanna do
is verify that the coroner
was absolutely certain
about the time of death.
Examination is not the time for argument.
The time of argument is
in your closing arguments.
- It's simple really, all we have to do is
cause the clock to sound,
right here and now.
- Yeah.
(dramatic chord)
- Okay, she's apparently
offering testimony as well.
- [Clock] It's 9:25.
- [Judge] That is certainly a bizarre way
to announce the time.
- [Larry] It's totally awesome,
I'm the voice of the thinker.
(cries out)
- [Judge] But I'm sorry to
say it doesn't prove anything
one way or another.
- So this judge is making
a classic mistake between
evidence being helpful, AKA probative
and being sufficient to
prove the entire case.
No one can ever prove their
case with one piece of evidence.
What your doing is you're
building a mountain
one stone at a time.
Or you're trying to
create reasonable doubt
one stone at a time.
And after a while if
you have enough stones
then you can have a mountain
of evidence in your favor.
Here the defense is
creating reasonable doubt
no thanks to their own
really terrible lawyering,
one piece at a time through
every piece of evidence.
It really, really bugs
me when I see people make
the same error that the
judge has here where they say
oh, that piece of evidence
whether it's in a trial
or in politics or what have you
and they say well that doesn't prove
what you're saying is true.
No maybe it doesn't but it helps prove it
and along with all this
mountain of evidence
that does prove the case
well you have to look at
everything weaved together.
The judge is not doing that here.
- But it doesn't matter one
bit if the clock is running
slow today, because you can't prove that
it was running slow on
the day of the murder.
- Again so this witness, in
addition to answering a question
that wasn't asked and the
attorney making an argument
in the middle of an examination
is make the same error that the judge is.
He's saying well just because
you've shown something
that's very damaging that
doesn't go all the way,
you know you've advanced 20 yards
but you haven't actually
entered the end zone.
He's saying well it's now worthless.
That's not true, you
made forward progress,
you might not have gotten all the way
but you're getting there
and you're putting all
the pieces together.
And together they've probably already
established reasonable doubt.
- Well got an answer for me?
Take that smart guy.
- Well as the attorney
he doesn't have to answer
any questions that you ask him.
- You got nothing on me pal.
- No he's got lots against you.
But also the defense attorney
here isn't trying to show
that the witness in particular
committed the murder,
all he has to do is show that there's
a reasonable doubt that his client did.
There's a big difference,
that's often why defendants
actually don't take the stand,
because it's not their burden to show
that they are innocent.
All you have to do is
show that the prosecution
hasn't met their burden or that
there is a reasonable doubt
associated with the prosecutors case.
The defense and especially
in a criminal case
bears no burden what so ever.
- If you have nothing further
I have no other option
than to release Mr. Sahwit from the stand.
- I take time out of my
day to relive this horrible
experience and you call me a murderer?
You might want to reconsider
your career Mr. Wright.
- And as with defendants if
there's no question pending
the witness should not be speaking.
And also if you need time
to look into something,
or to recoup then you
would just ask the judge
for a short recess, that's very common.
So you're gonna have time
to put things together,
it's not going at the break
neck pace of this anime.
- According to her passport
the victim had just been over seas,
the time difference between
Japan and New York is 14 hours.
So when it's four p.m.
here, it's two a.m. there.
Two is four.
- That's two hours difference.
- So this is not something
you would wanna bring up
with this particular witness
but there is a vehicle
to bring in evidence that is
basically incontrovertible
and it is called judicial notice.
If you have evidence of
something that you don't want
to bring in a particular witness,
for example if you wanted
to say the time difference
between New York and Tokyo is 14 hours,
you wouldn't want to have to go through
the expense of calling in
an expert in date and time.
It's a fact that's so incontrovertible
and easy to ascertain that the
judge should allow that fact
in without requiring someone to lay
what would normally be proper foundation.
So here though he should
not be making an argument
he would be able to ask the
judge to take judicial notice
of the fact that the time
difference is 14 hours,
that's something that would
come in virtually at anytime.
- The victim took the
clock with her on her trip
but she hadn't set it to
reflect local time yet.
- Well that's speculation.
- That's why the time you heard
was exactly two hours off.
The truth is Sahwit did it!
(crying out)
- Man I really wish I was
allowed to bring in evidence
when ever I felt like it
and make argument when ever I felt like it
but there are lots of laws
and rules that prevent me from doing that.
But with your help we can change that.
(cries out)
(thudding)
(banging)
- Arrest Mr Sahwit immediately.
- The judge is not responsible
for arresting people.
And in fact if the prosecutor
had seen this kind of evidence
he probably would have referred
the witness to the police
to arrest that man but that is not
the pre view of the judge in any case.
- I must say you've done
an incredible job today.
In your first trial you
defended your client
and discovered the true culprit.
- Thank you.
- Did he?
- And now it's time to
deliver the verdict.
(dramatic music)
Not guilty.
(cheering)
- Well there shouldn't
be a verdict at all,
the case just should have been dismissed.
The prosecutor should have realized that
it's crazy to continue
prosecuting this guy
so therefore he should just go home.
- [Man] All rise.
- So that was Phoenix
Wright, Ace Attorney.
Man I don't even know
what to do with that.
I don't know if that's accurate
from a Japanese perspective
but man from an American perspective
that is just all completely wrong.
The US constitution gives
the benefit of the doubt
to criminal defendants because
the founders recognized
that it was better for
a guilty man to go free
than an innocent man to be convicted
of a crime they didn't commit.
All of those things were
a due process violation
that probably would have
been overturned on appeal.
But it never should have
gotten to that point,
and frankly the lawyering on
the defense side was terrible,
he wasn't objecting when
he should have been,
he was allowing the other
side to make argument
when they shouldn't have been.
So all in all I would give
Phoenix Wright, Ace Attorney
a D-, it is all over the place,
it's all completely wrong
and it's a terrible example
of lawyering in general.
If you liked this video please
click like and subscribe
so you don't miss the
next lawyer reacts video.
And by the way I put together
a play list of all my prior
videos including my reaction
to the Good Wife and Suits.
I think you'll love it.